my name is Tim verse Tainan I'm the
director of the cognitive axon lab I
send the Department of Psychology and
the Center for the neural basis of
cognition here at CMU
so one of the things we're kind of
hoping to do in the lab and we're
working on right now is releasing
publicly available maps of the
anatomical connections in the human
brain the normal healthy brain with this
information you can do a lot of things
you can use them in educational
resources to teach how the brains wired
together teacher anatomical pathways in
the brain a lot of basic scientists are
interested in this in terms of trying to
understand whatever system they're
looking at visual system auditory system
you name it and then the other Avenue of
our research is really trying to
understand a very basic question about
how the brain learns how do we learn
from a moment-to-moment experiences and
how do certain parts of the way that
we're wired together make us better or
worse at learning you can understand
individual differences and this learning
ability if you understand the way the
system is put together and that's where
we kind of hoping to push this the most
so right now what we're doing is we're
using a form of magnetic resonance
imaging called diffusion-weighted
imaging to map out the physical
connections in the human brain and what
we're looking at is the large super
highways that connect different areas
together and by mapping out these
connections what we essentially get is a
wiring diagram of the human brain now in
the lab what we're interested in is
using this wiring diagram to understand
how we make very basic decisions we're
also looking at how particular set of
circuits the brain called the cortical
basal ganglia circuits allow for us to
learn very complex skills you acquire
these skills of our very long times go
so we're looking at this this form of
learning in the context of the
organization and the neural circuits
that are involved and in particular what
we want to know is does little
differences in the way that the circuits
organized across individuals predict
differences in the way that you say
learn a melody in the piano or learn to
make a decision about whether or not to
engage in action and we've identified in
collaboration with colleagues here a
novel molecular mechanism that might
explain how the environments and your
social factors can actually impact
little cells in your brain and that's
through something called the
inflammatory
pathways your body's inflammatory system
is part of your immune system and when
you are chronically stressed when you're
unhealthy when you're smoked physically
abuse you increase the circulating
inflammatory chemicals in your
bloodstream and what these do is they
cross the blood-brain barrier and can
induce little micro inflammation in the
brain particularly around cells that
protect these long range connections in
the brain we might be biased towards
individual abilities just because of the
way we're wired together naturally and
we might be biased by our social
environment or our health and we've
proposed a new field called health
neuroscience which is specifically
proposed to merge these ideas of health
psychology with the tools and questions
of cognitive neuroscience